the Joe Rogan experience so when you do
return mm-hmm
how you how long did you serve for nine
years nine years and when you made the
decision to get out mm-hmm what was what
was that decision based on so I never
really wanted to do the Navy as a
full-time career my entire life you know
do 20 years and get out and collect the
pension the war was starting to at the
time slow down ish for op tempo like how
quickly guys are going overseas and the
amount of action they're seeing the way
I saw it was it's like training for a
fight that you never do mmm I didn't
want that to be my life and I was 28 you
know I'm like you know what let me make
some phone calls and see how guys are
feeling about stuff overseas and because
I was out on the jump team at the time
right so I had like I didn't quite have
my finger on the pulse of what was
happening at the team so I made some
calls and those guys I can't man if
there's nothing really tying you down
like a like a kid or you know a huge
amount of dad or you know a lifelong
dream of this being your Navy SEAL for
20 years you know and you want to do
other stuff with your life might be a
good time to do it do and I'm happy I
did you know I I got out with all my
fingers and toes and I'm glad that I was
able to leave on really good terms and
feel really happy about what I did
because I feel like we were making a
difference when you say that like what
what made you feel like you were making
a difference the things I know that we
got to participate in the places we were
and the guys that we were moved from the
battlespace
captured or killed or [ __ ] [ __ ]
that we're using women and children as
targets and we're causing terror when
you say terrorist people have this
disassociated view of that now right
yeah just thrown across the newspapers
they were causing terror I don't think
people can you know the coronavirus
stuff is coming out now or when a bomb
goes off somewhere or there's a mass
shooting
imagine if that's your entire life yeah
if you're walking around town and that's
what's going on every damn day
your fault this is just some guy that's
deciding that's their their job in life
is to ruin yours and we were removing
them so I feel like we were doing a good
thing
[Applause]